ou si vous deviez partira quand ça sera
avec l animateur mais pas pour du sexe a
ici alors je n'y a généralement vacances
venir rapprochement veut dire des fois
si tôt
[Applaudissements]
oh
pourquoi vous crachez pas espagnol je
l'avais en chantant en allemand je
cherche je cracherais pas il dit même si
tôt voilà exactement il une bassine
d'eau alors immédiatement mais à quoi
lentement c'est à dire doucement décès
dans l'aude espagne alors agathe c'est
quoi non mais par contre on a fait un
classement des animateurs les plus beaux
avec ma meilleure amie et vous étiez
très bien placé pour la truite
mais ces deux îles tonga lé pa pas du
tout va bien il y avait des jeunes qui
tu veux pas paramétrer votre meilleur
ami votre meilleur ami et non voyantes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je constate que des deux côtés la place
numéro deux c'est les lécheurs de boules
de la place numéro 4 s'est pas la place
de l'humour
[Musique]
[Rires]
alors oui voilà oui donc je partirai en
toute amitié avec cyril féraud il va pas
faire que des mots creux mais c'est
justement on pourrait faire des mots
croisés sur la plage on pourrait amener
mon grand père c'est ce que trop bien
le collet va te faire un bon fesci il y
tient beaucoup reconnaît cyril attention
il peut chauffer